It goes without saying that Ace and his role
in the story of One Piece, have been a wildly
controversial topic.
Many adore his character for its cool and
charming design, while many others criticise
it for its lack of character development and
impulsive behaviour.
And at the height of this debate stands of
course the CLIMAX of Ace´s tragic story arc:
his defeat by Blackbeard, his capture by the
Marines, his liberation by Luffy and finally,
his sacrifice for his younger brother.
A common point of criticism regarding Ace´s
death, is that Ace did not have enough character
development to make his death feel impactful
enough.
And while emotional connection to a character
is, and always WILL be, a subjective experience
for EVERY one of us, I find that this argument
is somewhat missing the point of Ace´s role
in the story.
Because not every character in a story can,
or even SHOULD undergo character development.
In fact there are three types of character
arcs that a character can go through: Positive
change, negative change or, no change at all.
Ace, just as many other important side characters
in the story, has a FLAT character arc; meaning
he doesn’t change his view on the world,
but stays a constant throughout his appearances
in the story.
His entire life, Ace is struggling with the
legacy of his fathers name, having to suffer
under both the burning hatred as well as the
flaming admiration people had for Roger.
Being born as the son of the WORST criminal
of his age, until his very last moment, Ace
is struggling to find meaning in his life
and whether he ever deserved to live in the
first place.
The ONE thing he can cling on to is his burning
will to protect his friends and family from
any harm.
His death therefore, was one of the most SHOCKING
events in the entirety of One Piece.
Especially so, since Oda is very careful and
averse when it comes to killing off characters.
And most importantly, Ace´s death was not
a Disney death, where the person comes back
to life in the end.
No, what makes this moment so INCREDIBLY powerful
is that it is FINAL, and has real consequences.
And therefore, in this video, I want to talk
about the tragedy of Portages D. Ace, and
why his death is one of THE fundamental cornerstones
of the One Piece story.
Because Luffy loosing his beloved older brother
not only deepens our protagonist´s character,
but it ALSO advances the plot in a crucial
way, and of course also impacts US, the readers,
emotionally.
When I talk about how Ace´s death has deepened
Luffy´s character, I believe it goes MUCH
deeper than simply showing Luffy that he has
to become stronger.
In fact, Luffy already was aware of this back
on Water 7, when he talks to Bruno about his
devastating defeat by Aokiji.
And of course, loosing his crew to Kizaru
and Kuma, against both of whom he stood not
the slightest chance, also made Luffy realise
that he had to become much more powerful.
So no; Ace´s death was NOT simply a way for
Luffy to become stronger.
Loosing his treasured older brother, whom
he had shared such a happy and adventurous
childhood with, shook Luffy to his core and
from there developed his character fundamentally.
Having the loving bond with his brother cut,
JUST when he had managed to finally do the
impossible and save him from the marines,
threw Luffy into deep distress and despair.
Being characterised by his positive, easy-going
and at times naive nature, Luffy has to learn
that not every obstacle can be overcome through
determination alone.
For the FIRST time EVER, he was not able to
fulfil a goal he set himself.
He gave EVERYTHING he had to save his brother,
and still he failed.
He realises that loss and failure are things
that can actually happen to him if he is not
willing to take things seriously.
But it goes even further than this.
It makes Luffy question his entire purpose
for setting out to sea.
Loosing BOTH, his crew AND Ace, it is an absolute
low point in his adventure.
However, the experience allows him to realise
that his crew are not only his friends, but
his FAMILY, and that he has to grow significantly
in order to be able to protect them from Ace´s
fate.
Thus, he literally inherits Ace´s will to
protect those he holds dear at any cost.
It is the decicive trigger for Luffy, to become
the powerful and more mature captain he is
today.
And finally, seeing his brother murdered in
front of his eyes also gave Luffy his first
ever antagonist, that he resents on a PERSONAL
level.
Killing Ace and literally BURNING the mark
of his death into Luffy´s chest, is a permanent
visual reminder of what the Admiral did to
our protagonist.
In the end, Luffy comes out of his grieve
as a stronger, wiser and overall more mature
captain, facing a strong antagonist that he
truly resents with ALL his heart.
But Ace´s tragic character arc does even
MORE for the story than developing Luffy.
It advances the plot line SIGNIFICANTLY and
sets the stage for the second half of the
story.
While some people disliked Ace´s defeat by
Blackbeard and his subsequent capture by the
world government, these events not only introduced
Blackbeard as Luffy´s biggest rival for the
story, but it placed Luffy, as Ace´s little
brother, right at the CENTER of the Impel
Down and Marineford arcs.
This was crucial, since both arcs did not
only introduce a ton of important new characters,
but also rang in the end of Roger´s and Whitebeard´s
era and the beginning of a new age.
Since ACE wanted to make WHITEBEARD King of
the pirates, and WHITEBEARD in turn to make
ACE pirate King, there was little room for
Luffy to come closer to his goal.
The new power vacuum created by Whitebeard´s
death was not only convenient, but NECESSARY
for BOTH Luffy AND Blackbeard to have a realistic
shot at finding the One Piece.
And this war taking place and Luffy being
able to be present there, was only possible,
because his adopted brother, the son of the
former pirate King himself, was to be publicly
executed and politicised by the world government.
And beside that, the war AND Luffy´s tragic
loss also served as a midpoint climax to the
entire series, which gave the adventure a
fresh start after the time skip and better
pacing overall.
In this context it also allowed us to see
Luffy reflect upon his childhood with Ace
and Sabo, and thus gave us a much deeper look
into the development and history of his character.
So to put it shortly: Ace´s character was
designed to enable CRUCIAL plot development
for the one piece story that resulted in one
of the most POPULAR arcs of the series AND
set the stage for the second half of the adventure
in the new world.
Now, It would be quite heartless of me of
course, to say that Ace´s character was simply
an elegant tool, smartly fit into the story
to develop Luffy and the plot.
Because, as I said in the beginning, for many,
Ace was a DEEPLY likeable character.
Thus, his death obviously had a strong emotional
impact on us readers as well.
However, even if you did not like or care
for Ace TOO much before his execution, I think
that the moment he died was nonetheless powerful
for pretty much any reader.
Because not only did Ace sacrifice his just
regained life for his little brother Luffy,
but Oda also found a quite emotional, and
yet weirdly satisfying end to his character
arc.
Firstly, the true MAGNITUDE of a minor characters
death is ALWAYS defined by the reaction of
the hero, who we all emphasise with.
And Luffy´s reaction to Ace´s death might
very well be the most POWERFUL and HEARTBREAKING
thing we have had to witness in the entire
series so far.
This fact alone gave this moment, and thus
Ace´s character, a lot of meaning; actually
making him even MORE popular after his death.
And secondly, Ace finally managed to find
an answer to the question that has haunted
him his entire life: Why do I live?
All his life Ace was known for never turning
his back on an enemy, no matter HOW strong
they were.
And when he finally accepts WHITEBEARD and
his men as his new family, he proudly wears
his mark on his back, where it could never
be harmed.
Because Ace was known for never turning his
back on an enemy.
And yet, DESPITE his pride, the LAST thing
he does is turning his back on Akainu in order
to protect his family.
Having Luffy and Whitebeard taking on the
world government for his sake shows him that
people actually do care whether he lives or
not.
He actually deserves to live.
And so just having found his answer, he chooses
to protect his family over all else.
And this will, he then inherits to Luffy.
What we can take away from all this, is that
Ace´s character is much more than a cool
older brother who’s death motivated Luffy
to train for two years and get stronger.
The hardship and doubt that he carried in
his heart his entire life, as well as the
love he felt for his family, lead to the most
IMPACTFUL event in the story up to this point.
Not only did he give significant character
development to Luffy, but he also shaped and
developed the plot of the story in a number
of crucial ways.
And in the end, his death drove home one of
the most, if not THE most, important theme
in One Piece: Following your dreams.
Because, with Ace dying in the end with a
smile on his face, just as his father did,
Oda tells us that if you pursue your dream
and strive for what you really wanted in life,
you will have a happy ending.
Hey everyone, thank you so much for watching.
What are your thoughts on Ace and his story?
And what character would you like to see me
discuss next?
Share your thoughts with me in the comments
below.
If you enjoy One Piece and want to learn more
about story-telling, world-building or my
thoughts on the latest One Piece chapter,
make sure to like and subscribe to become
part of the channel right now.
I hope to see you around next time.
And.
Until then.
Stay safe and have a wonderful week.